je crois que personne n'a intérêt à
rentrer dans une bataille de chiffres
sur le sujet des sans abri et des
personnes qui sont dans la misère qui
souffrent beaucoup et l'état les
collectivités locales notamment la ville
de paris travaillent main dans la main
c'est une situation ancienne ce n'est
pas le gouvernement actuel qui a créé
les sans abri c'est nous savons depuis
voilà plusieurs années c'est réalité de
nos villes une réalité très malheureuse
nos vies et les associations d'ailleurs
connaissent la situation parfois même
très personnellement des des sans abri
sur l'opération de jeudi soir c'était
une opération légitime sans arrière
pensées politiques
6 s'il s'agit de compter comme cela a
été fait dans d'autres villes voilà
pourquoi pas mais je crois que à new
york notamment mais je crois pas que ce
soit le plus important le plus important
c'est de travailler pour améliorer la
situation
sortons des polémiques politiciennes et
disons nous quand même que conté ne
suffit pas s'il suffisait de dénombrer
les sans abri pour trouver des solutions
on le saurait et d'ailleurs les
associations connaissent déjà la
situation mais en revanche il faut c'est
proposer des solutions notamment sur un
parcours du logement ce sera l'objectif
de la loi est lent la loi portée par
julien de normandie et jacques mézard
sur le fait de faire comme dans certains
pays du nord certains pays scandinaves
où on met le logement d'abord par
exemple en évitant les expulsions
locatives ya tout de même eu des
maladresses de communication de la part
des macros nice on pense notamment à
sylvain maillard qui est un élu parisien
et puis assuré que la majorité des sdf
dorment et dans la rue par choix est-ce
que ça a pas mal à créer un contexte un
peu particulier sur ce débat
sylvain maillard a reconnu la maladresse
de sa phrase qui a d'ailleurs été
amputée parce qu'il n'a pas exactement
dit cela pour le connaître je sais que
c'est un homme qui est empreint
d'humanisme et évidemment dans son for
intérieur il ne voulait absolument pas
dire cela parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est profondément humain et comme le sont
d'ailleurs les habitants des grandes
villes qui souffrent aussi de voir ces
personnes dans la difficulté
donc ce que je pense sur ce sujet c'est
que de l'autre côté d'ailleurs aussi
certains ont voulu relancer
débat sur les chiffres il ne s'agit pas
d'un débat sur les chiffres parce que
les situations sont très différentes
vous avez des personnes à la rue qui
sont seules des familles avec enfants
des gens qui souffrent de psychoses liés
à l'alcool des personnes migrantes donc
il faut à chaque fois des solutions
logement différentes et c'est là qu'est
la difficulté c'est que il faut être
tout faire du cas par cas et éviter un
certain nombre d'amalgamés et de
généralités qui n'apportent aucune
solution concrète pour les prêts minutes
18 20